as Trump was relaunching his re-election
campaign in Florida Tuesday night our
own Raymond Arroyo talked to protesters
at an anti Trump event just blocks away
they revealed a new line of thinking on
the left a deeply negative view of their
home country your placard says America
was never great why do you say that I
don't know people do you get our lands
but I mean we're all free we can come
out here and say our piece right I think
yours on the wrong side of the bridge
trying to kick Raven off all that
language might be expected from an
activist I guess but more prominent
voices are now contributing to the
warped mindset right here these things
about let's make America great again I
think of myself exactly when did you
think America was great we're not gonna
make America great again it was never
that great there's things that are
savagely wrong in this country what
we're seeing in this country doesn't
reflect our spirit what we're seeing in
this country doesn't reflect reflect our
potential what's one of the greatest
times ever to be an American is right
now joining me now with reaction former
Speaker of the House Fox News
contributor Newt Gingrich Newt are we
blowing this out of proportion tonight
or have many of the most prominent vocal
voices and then the activists on the
ground really just now very blatant
about defaming the foundations and
accomplishments of our home country I
mean the hatred is palpable well I think
it's kind of amazing that President
Trump has this knack for framing things
in such a way that his opponents go
crazy so you now have for example the
president says keep America great which
i think is a great campaign slogan for
next year the Democrats promptly say no
no keep America weak the president says
I'm proud to be an American the Left
says I'm ashamed to be an American the
number of lies being told right now
about the United States are just
astonishing but all Trump is doing is
is drawing to the surface the deep
hatred which on campuses certainly began
by the middle of the 1960s and has grown
and grown like a cancer and you're now
seeing it with leading national
Democrats and they have a real problem
if you want to be a Democrat today and
go to a normal democratic meeting and
start talking about how wonderful
America is how great the founding
fathers were how remarkable the
Constitution is you'd be booed off the
stage so the Democrats will begin to be
the party which is a genuinely
anti-american party and that's pretty
remarkable yeah I mean we've moved from
like when I was in college in the 1980s
it was you know Ronnie Raygun remember
there was like he's gonna Muslim
mushroom crap cloud over the Soviet
Union and it was just ridiculing him we
all kind of forget that now and the glow
of Reagan biographers but they were just
trashing Reagan but they were really
saying America and her core is
illegitimate because her founding was
illegitimate her founders were racist
but this is just grown knit with social
media and grown with this the prevalence
of 24-hour media and the Academy is just
there embolden Hollywood's emboldened
and you're right though Trump adds this
way of just drawing out their utter
anti-american madness I think the
regular people look at this going wait I
love my country I fly my flag I love my
country it's not where no one's perfect
well my god I wouldn't want to live
anywhere else
you know in 1984 at the Republican
convention Jean Kirkpatrick the
ambassador to the United Nations capture
this and she had been Hubert Humphreys
advisor on domestic policy she actually
was originally sort of a moderate
Democrat and she had gradually been
driven out of the party by the left wing
and she gave this amazing speech which
is worth our audience googling and
pulling up which he talked about the
blame America first Democrats that
they're always blaming America first
well if you watched the last three or
four days talk about concentration camps
which is just a total absolute lie
I mean it is smearing America it is
insulting to everybody who's genuinely
worried about the Holocaust and the
concentration camps in which six million
Jews were killed and millions of other
people were killed and yet on the Left
today as we watched recently with Vice
President Biden Biden telling the truth
about friendships that were unacceptable
out there more damaging than Alexandria
cose
saying things that are absolutely
totally false but feel good if you're a
left winger it's false defamatory and
and I think deeply vindictive at its
core but Newt I also get quick thoughts
on what's happening with these
heightened tensions between the u.s. and
Iran so asked if the US was gonna
retaliate after one of our drones were
shot down the president had this to say
today Iran made a big mistake and they
made a very bad mistake you'll find out
new thoughts how should we respond well
I think the president is doing the right
thing I mean he's not going to trigger
what he's gonna do I suspect at the
highest levels we're talking right now
with the Iranians and we're saying look
now you have a huge problem either you
take full responsibility in which case
we will have to retaliate or you have to
fire somebody I mean if you want a claim
oh as a subordinate fine
fire them but if you're willing to take
responsibility well we're moving but
remember this because we're energy
independent because of the policies of
Donald Trump we are actually exporting
energy so we're not affected by the
Straits of Hormuz China India Japan
Europe they have a huge investment in
this and I suspect a one-level we're
saying to them you want to come and help
us patrol the Straits of Hormuz cuz
you're the ones whose economy will crash
those straits get closed good let's
spread the burden mr. speaker fantastic
that's right tonight as always